hey guys today we are going to finish
inside let's finish a game I can't wait
to find out what is actually going on in
this game because as you guys probably
guess from last episode I'm just bloody
confused the let's finish this together
and see if any of our theories were
correct because I thought he was a robot
last episode so hmm la la I'm so excited
to finish this game mmm I feel like this
game whenever I think I understand
what's going on um I don't it seemed you
know a little bit crazy when you could
mind control people that was crazy um
but it's just got even more crazy after
that like we can control gravity with
the water we can breathe underwater
there's people with weird heads that are
like mannequins I just don't know what's
going on but will soon find out oh and
also yeah I did cheat you a little bit I
know what to do here I was totally stuck
on this okay dumb don't judge me I was
so stuck and now I kind of know what I'm
doing cuz the door opens when the waters
like that and then we can jump on the
box I thought we had to kind of block
the door with the box but no jump on the
box then you go into the water like so
perfect he's so lucky that those people
are not looking out the window realizing
what's going on
we okay well they are they bombs they
don't know little bombs sit down see
what's down here what
what I think see are they real people
all the dummies can you tell are they
hello are you a real person you're
wearing underwear and if you were a
robot I'm guessing you wouldn't really
need unto us and maybe they are real
people I don't know when this people can
they see me oh this one anything hmm I
have no idea what's going on I thought I
would have more of an idea the more that
I played the game but nope I'm just
having more questions can't wait can't
wait for the game to tell me i love i
love the way John still I want to go to
that button don't I oh yeah it's that
button I wish you could just go this way
and go in that door that's clearly open
behind him but no you can only run
certain ways maybe that's how he was
programmed to me he's a robot don't make
sense now
oh my god that hurt the guy who broke
his neck definitely died see so I think
the candor and the our people oh my gosh
stop it yeah it's so creepy some of them
don't even have arms and stuff hey hey
hey are they are they creating people
you know oh my gosh that's so creepy
that person's on the floor trying to
come with us are they their body parts
are slowly falling off them aren't they
this is so creepy right sorry right
let's just go let's just go um you know
how they do it to animals so that we can
eat they have genetically mutant well
it's wrong looks do that guy on the end
where is his head where is his head like
oh yeah what we're trying to say is it's
not genetically mutated as it's um ah
you know they create animals and stuff
in test tubes they're not even born and
others are they doing that to humans
okay guys those of you that have arms
help me out those of you that don't just
try oh that was rubbish that was my
fault though it's not you guys oh sorry
I tripped a guy over
check out there how we gonna do this
guy's they're still trying to follow us
but they don't have any legs I'm sorry
hey maybe I can put you back together
yeah I just tried to pick him up I can't
do that
that must be really freaky he's a tiny
little boy and he's just surrounded by
all these naked people I think it might
be you know genetic mutation maybe
they're trying to make super humans
they're trying to make the excellent
here we go put me up here they're still
following me then I come now come down
and we're gonna have to try and time it
so i can press that button I think I am
and they'll catch me on the bottom ah
see they're lovely little bit creepy but
they're lovely right yeah whoa let's go
see there they are they are they're
making people for work forces and self
Sawyer just clicked in your face but
they're they're making people to do
menial job tasks that's the word isn't
it me not you know where job tasks that
perhaps maybe other people won't want to
do all they need a big workforce to help
them okay stop with the conspiracy
theories and display the game this is
bad idea this was very bad idea they
survived we died sure well oh no sorry
but we already know that they didn't
dies was okay
hmm what now this is a bunch of people
running in that way oh they're already
down there so we can just jump on them
save me oh thank you you're you're too
kind right bye
there's blood there's blood on the floor
hey guys see you
my free following me okay how they go
here we go they'll just fall down here
hi and there's two guys so nice to see
you is there anything out there can you
give me a boost I want to buy secrets
nope can't go out there that is so
creepy get away from me I don't want
your bodies rubbing up against me this
so like me on the tube in London okay we
did things right the Me's exchanged
everyone with arms help me
do for each other like football like
human dominoes I think we're right you
know i think they are creating humans in
a disgusting kind of way in test tubes
or whatever using water to keep them in
prime condition and the ones who are in
a constant state of suspension on wires
maybe they hadn't been fully created yet
maybe they were still in the process of
being made that's why they have it
messed up blossom okay because we can
use that phone you guys have thrown off
the hook bone why people running
everywhere something happened
what the hell is that
so creepy why they got cameras
everywhere oh no is this for a TV show
like a reality TV too and they're making
oh hi nice sir why are you running what
are you running to get me because I know
what are they not trying to get him
anymore Oh looking over here I want to
see what are you looking at i want to
see
give me a most people I want to see what
are you looking at it won't let us learn
my waiting for something I go back maybe
I can smash the window no no those are
ladder back here I do really want to
know what they're looking at can we just
not see okay so yeah
oh that's cool as a light broke the
light bulb sorry won't pay for it but
whatever i'll be going into that room
where they were looking at yeah yeah
this is the room they're all looking
right what are they doing
some water in there are they watching
that girl the our friend
what's in there are they cameras what
what do i do enjoy jump on it okay that
was close cool what is this that's cool
oh yeah jump on the top of it dirt
he's so brave we'll have to climb up way
ok you can't climb up anymore so very
climb down
he's very nimble is this the what is
this ok this is underneath whatever they
were looking into your thing and the
very bottom
glad we can swim now
damn
I need to swim downwards let's go take a
while guys this could take a while but
I'm going to try my hardest to get down
think I'm suspended okay fine whatever
let's go up here oh we can't okay it
might be a button stuff something
everything I really hope you guys are as
excited as I am Oh No
I'm gonna do that if it takes a while to
turn on we can grab it oh come on we can
do this oh no oh that was awesome okay
you ready yeah whoa oh yeah whoa I'm
naked ah naked oh my god they were
watching me what okay I'm naked there's
a blob of humans a blob of humans it's
oh my god are you okay what is this is
this oh my god i am totally totally
right they're getting what's that word
genetically creating I don't even know
that's my word they're just making
humans oh my god the time I means the
ball
oh I'm moving the ball I am the ball ego
let's give you something to look out yes
kuru you get away from the glass I wanna
smash this glass oh my gosh we are
breaking through yes crew you
oh my god I feel I feel like I'm sin
from spirited away I love it oh can we
jump there we can't jump oh no I'm sorry
kill my friends are they gonna be sucked
into the oh my god they can carry us
there yes super strong I commend your
strengths and abilities
this is disgusting it's a little boy
okay
it's happy
since you like that in characters face
it away
why do they have a little miniature seen
here okay yag man stop asking questions
just enjoy being a monster for once
don't look at me I will kill you of a
stump on you and I will eat you and
you'll become part of me strong this is
what humans have the ability to do we
combined strengths we will be
unstoppable
what was the point in that
oh okay so I need to get up to that haha
oh this is so hard to control this is so
disgusting look at the people just
watching like it has brains it knows
what it's doing it's trying to get up on
the ledge it has intelligence there's
gonna be one of those crazy scientists
it gets out in front of it it's like bad
babe look and then we just kill it
lunchtimes over guys get a cat too I'm
gonna catch you
yeah sorry about this but uh you did
this to yourself this is discuss I did
not expect this from inside okay let's
let's take a bath wash all this blood
off us not quite sure that's how it
works bloodstains ok let's try and oh
let's try and touch this button hey
water and tea work let's defeat the dogs
dogs ain't got nothing on us anymore
we're not a little boy we are I don't
know what we are we are giant clump of
human matter that is extremely
terrifying and pretty disturbing you
know
how we gonna do this goody the dopes to
stay on him dougie is staying here get
this dogs you're so annoying you can't
stop this oh my god I serve like that
calling out for help they will like okay
now go go go go go go go up here yes
made it make you a meeting we have the
brains of like a thousand men in here or
at least a dozen and woman I mean Mendes
of mankind okay we just killed a few of
those so maybe not that much anymore
it's just a guy in there like what it's
happening
late again hey well waive him to open
the door go on then open the door go
girl be free briefly we're letting you
be free
misc friesen see why didn't he run
through that wait are they trying to
help us or they tryna lead us somewhere
where are you trying to leave it to I
untrustyou i think i have to trust you
they're not running away themselves so
maybe i'll try to help us
like there's a rebel group that have
infiltrated the evil people and they're
tryna help Alice how powers help Alice
that makes sense it's so gross the
animations for this is great though what
was that noise buzzer beat did you hear
it ah so awkward oh hey again nice nice
I wonder thinking similar Wilson how he
legs oh this is where they wanted us to
go to incinerate ourselves well I mean
oh this is quite disgusting isn't it I
mean they can't exactly be let free in
the world now I mean I don't even think
they'd want to and if they do have
intelligence which they obviously do
because they've just completed some
puzzles to get down here they probably
want to go I wouldn't want to be like
that okay guys come on sorry
were they real people where they just
made from the beginning we can't go in
we can't you in I'm trying we can't go
in
I don't know know what those beeping
swear maybe we got to incinerate this
box instead of ourselves that I was
thinking as a suicide ending
where's that supposed to go
okay you've said these on now how does
that help us no way that we can not get
this box where
unless we check it like
oh my gosh we're doing yet okay
whoa oh I'm so excited we got it yeah
don't really know what we're doing with
this box I think we're getting smaller
as a as a group body parts keep falling
up I mean we are how many a burning
cross whoa we're gonna blow this place
so disturbing I do not expect this to be
one of the most disturbing daiba I came
to better played um certainly is not her
again but yeah it's very disturbing how
do we get there
uh-huh
what's in there hey green maybe it's
plants from that underground forest that
we saw it's not that easy being you know
a blob of humans it's just not whoa guys
if I were you I would maybe maybe run
maybe I don't know you obviously are
under estimating the power
we're gonna need to throw this and have
it yeah and have it no I need you to get
up on it and pull that thing someone
needs to pull pull the lever on the
thing ok ok someone needs a pole the
lever are you listening to me know as
are you listening to me you to pull the
lever hey dude can you pull the lever
for us please we can't do it can are you
gonna help us you pull the lever you are
are you lovely thank you ever so much
yeah you're very very helpful yeah we
have friends fights work a guy away oh
it was too busy celebrating you need to
do again so I work a guy typical me ok
always celebrating with how I've
actually like got to the very end goo
goo goo yes ok
what's this book is all about they
trying to tempt us with mum we can't
grab it and whoa that's like a big crowd
of people it's washing us why why you
tempt ears with it oh oh they were
tricking us
what do we do now ah we're tearing it
but what's he's strong let's go we're
free with the fishes this is so strange
oh this is noisy that was the first we
are terrified what huge we're bigger
than treats to see I mean forget that
big I don't think we're that big we're
gonna find out why they were made what
was the purpose of this big bowl of
goopy human flesh that everyone was
staring at
what
No
let the ant
what I wanted to find out why they were
being made where they made for a bit bad
company that what doing illegal things
and they need more people to work for
them where they are made for military
purposes where they made for TV show
entertainment purposes the media why was
they made ah ok so that ending was
extremely unexpected I think that is
actually the most unexpected ending i
have ever seen any game I'm not even
exaggerating I really just don't see
that one coming I'm a little bit upset
that they didn't explain everything to
expel 'used but I get they probably left
it open to interpretation so I would
love to hear your interpretations why do
you think this blobby goop of human mess
was created I want to know what you
think I personally think maybe it was
simply just human greed we're constantly
trying to push science and see how far
we can go saying that it's for good
purposes you know perhaps for for
transplants for healing cancer you know
all this kind of stuff but where do we
cross the line you know where is it just
been taken too far because I know
they're already starting to make organs
and body parts stuff like that in a
laboratory is that a good thing or is
that a bad thing this kind of makes you
think doesn't it and where did that
little boy end up her boy is gone and I
do think it's kind of about that about
how science is evolving how the future
could possibly end up are we really the
good ones are have we overstepped our
boundary or are we about to that's what
I take from this other people might have
complete different presumptions I'm
gonna go now and binge watch a lot of
people playing inside to see what their
reactions were cuz they're ending was
amazing that ending was mind-blowing let
me know in the comments below what you
thought this was all about I really want
to start to get some awesome
conversations going I think there's a
lot to be said about the end of this
game thank you so much for watching my
let's play of inside if you want more
let's plays such as this one
please give this a thumbs up it really
helps me a lot to see whether you guys
enjoy these types of videos or not and
as always subscribe if you wanna I don't
tell you very often to subscribe because
I feel like I'm a like a Paul but yet do
if you want to see more of my face have
another daring me by give me out the
water oh oh oh why does she scare me
like that what do i do nothing like
hitting tonight should i just hug her
she's gonna kill me but i'm still alive